[Music]
what is up there stranger than fiction
things fans you guys see that movie
strange in the fiction it's not a bad
movie no it's pretty good goodwill feral
performance in there guys we got a four
out of four here welcome to california
that's where we're from california
but now we live here in idaho potato
town sorry for being late to this i was
just really sick this morning i still
might look a little bit out of it i'm
afraid to eat anything right now i was
so sick i was uh
[Music]
dear mike
today is day 185.
nice shank i have finally adapted
hopper
well
jonathan's still
doing hold down here
oh my
i even like school now
[Music]
spring break
look how big will is i know so tall
i am ready for spring break
because i get to see you
bullied
i will have the best spring break ever
you know what that means
i got some chills some chaos at the end
i had nutrition in my body i'd have more
shits
i got some nipple chills feel the nip oh
yeah oh yeah feel the nip that is a hard
nip right there
yeah
when he says that he's not lying i want
you all to be very clear on that oh i
mean he's got to come out of spring
break then right yeah that's what they
do they're gonna put it out during
summer vacation to confuse everybody
this was stranger things they tend to
release their [ __ ] around when their
show takes place yeah if i'm not
mistaken that's what their weird model
is it's not weird it's actually really
apt and awesome that they do that and i
think more things should do that season
five christmas
dude
christmas thing
how cool would that be
i'm serious like make a checklist of all
the times of year you want to get
specific about what the stranger thinks
season and then you get your like spooky
christmas vibe it'd be perfect like
alongside a krampus viewing or something
her and mike are still in touch that was
a really sweet letter she was writing
it's interesting after the end of season
three there's a letter that she's
receiving from hopper that this would
start off with the levin's journey where
she's now writing a letter
to mike
that's the origin of her writing letters
was she was inspired by hopper and
that's how she's keeping his legacy
alive breakdowns easter eggs yeah we
can't let go of hopper can't let go of
hop especially because the show already
revealed he'd be back last season
as their first teaser we're gonna come
through a lot we got russia we got
california and we got hawkins what the
hell's hawkins
we got russian california that's it
california because where's california
it's like all the places you recognize
actually i do have a genuine thought
will and eleven hanging out i think
they've never really had much screen
time together in all the seasons of
stranger things right not like just them
as characters to get feel like they've
done mostly ensemble moments together
yeah and so they kind of form this like
brother sister dynamic now that's a cool
way to like keep the show fresh honestly
sometimes you try to think of like crazy
new plot things or whatever a lot of the
times it can just come in the form of
what happens if we pair these two
characters up more often what would the
chemistry and dynamics be like between
them and let's see how that unfolds and
i feel like we're going to get some of
that here especially like shitty thing
with 11 being bullied in school oh she
doesn't have her powers right now she
was taken away at the end of season
three uh-oh
and it's never coming back how is she
going
to demolish school bullies now oh man
just with harsh words and fisty cuffs
when she gets her powers back it's going
to be fully caring full-on character i
know right crush the entire school oh
that's going to be fantastic really
looking forward to that yeah we got the
actor who plays jonathan who's never had
any real public life problems
now doing illegal substances in
california in the 80s it's going to be a
real big stretch for that actor this
guy's never had to do anything
i thought he could build a character
around real life experiences
i mean nowadays that is totally legal
but back then the legal substance making
me go real life guy
you didn't want to ask them to maybe not
do that this season okay
guys can we avoid this plotline could
you avoid putting it in the trailer to
clue people in that that's my main
character beat this season all right
guys here's what we're gonna do all
right now we got obs running you you
tell us what everything that we got
wrong because odds are we're not gonna
get anything wrong okay so levin looks
like she's in this van right here yeah
right from the earlier times she's
pulled out in the desert looking at the
body of joe pesci buried there pinko
mania roller skating pinkos because we
got russia and communism and pinkos are
like communist sympathizers really yes
that's from history
yes so that's a clue and it's definitely
not just a fun
roller skating rink
and then we got dolls here
there was something to do with a
character before involving dolls
so we can only assume more doll
activities wait a minute no murray if i
i heard this recently
murray had uh
there's something in an earlier thing
with him involving putting messages and
polls i'm like totally making that up in
my own head
maybe we could google it or something
with hopper
someone with dolls
that's why you're here
[Laughter]
someone's firing a gun
we don't see who this individual is it's
matt murdock he's got the harry on
he looks like an fbi agent this gunshot
seems to be from and that's is that will
uh
that's mike and jonathan someone's
shooting from their bedroom yeah but
they have like art stand stuff up so
maybe they're visiting will's house in
this moment actually maybe mike's in
town yeah there's murray prison
transport keep back
so she's being transported as an
official government prisoner yeah
all right and then we get better clues
here okay there's something going on in
this desert oh oh and then an expansion
of the fight scene oh hey oh this
person's on their side who's firing the
god
protecting that that could be hoppy dude
or or some kind of new cool private eye
character wow you do learn a lot when
you start what do you slow down all
right guys what'd you think of this
stranger things trailer hope you enjoyed
it hey subscribe click bells hit like
buttons and let's do a p
sarah campbell sarah my dear you know
whenever john and i talk to you i get
the sense that lately your life has been
a little bit routine you need to start
doing some stranger things okay i'm
thinking you got to start eating
spaghettios with a sausage pepperoni
pizza what what oh what it doesn't get
stranger things then yeah you gotta
start getting a bidet for your toilet
and then using it to wash your hands
what stranger things that's sarah
campbell yeah that's what makes it a
stranger thing that's what this show is
about it's about doing stranger things
it's a game show ride a car as a
skateboard ride a car it's a stranger
thing that's not what cars are for
i'm thinking stranger things and missed
out on a really good opportunity for a
gamer
like campbell yeah maybe cross the
border kidnap the daughter of a
political figure oh stranger things dude
put some peanut butter on a railroad
track and then leave for several days
come back and see if it's attracted any
people who look like you strangers
stranger things things
i think they were dead no we could go
straight through a stranger
[Music]